I'm Erin Donna a bleach report to build
my all-time super bulletin I gotta go
ready he won six Super Bowl so you know
you're gonna find a way to win
we're running back Barry Sanders we make
you miss make you look silly I said a
lot of crazy how I like to do he's
consistent you know he Gogi to say he
gonna dominate every single time similar
same way DB that's prime time I was at a
prime time I hate reading for me return
to to both of them but you know prime
time we did some stuff and linebacker
he's a freak he's a freaking do it all
so he's gonna we're locking in it so I
put Tom Brady at quarterback obviously
because he won six Super Bowl so you
know he's gonna find out what he wanted
consistent Barry Sanders like he wanted
my favorite running backs ever you know
you ever seen him play some of the
things you can do you know he gonna go
make them big play when you need it on
the run game Jerry Rice is consistently
dominated you know three years when he
played Deion Sanders prime time we
return it can write the ball do a lot of
different things it and if you catch the
ball get a pick six you know you're
going school and Lawrence Taylor you
know one of the best defensive players
they ever do it get out to the
quarterback and do it all so that's my
pick right there
Aldi player Harris consistently did it
when eight when they play consistently
didn't he ran a year out you know so I'm
all it's a consistent football play and
I think the guys are who it is just here
with stickers opponent
you know Super Bowl commercial maybe but
know that as they do you know you had a
story eat a Snickers were the world out
of snow let's feed the world of Snickers
and and make the world better so just
part of fun commercial 20 commercial and
happy to be able Snickers